almost 40 percent of traffic deaths over
memorial day weekend
involve alcohol but now a technology
supported by big automakers promises to
help create what developers call
a world without drunk driving errol
barnett is testing it out he's in a car
with the high tech tool in virginia
errol
good morning hey there good morning let
me show you these orange sensors around
me are the drivers
alcohol detection system for safety and
this screen which we have up for demo
purposes
has a green line showing you how much
alcohol is being detected in
my breath it's at zero right now the
mission critical here is to stop drunk
driving before it begins
and prevent families from experiencing
unimaginable pain
he never took another breath patricia
kimmel recalling the moment
her son stephen died we watched all of
his veins turn blue
because of lack of oxygen in his body
and my hands were on his chest
just because i wanted to feel his heart
until
it stopped altogether t-boned in 2018 by
a drunk driver
stephen kimmel's car flipped three times
before ejecting him
it was the other driver's third drunk
driving arrest
kimmel says it's unacceptable that this
continues to happen
it's beyond belief because again it's
100 percent
preventable no alcohol detected a
promising new technology
more than a decade and 100 million
dollars in the making
is aimed at preventing such accidents i
hope this is the next seat belt
fits in your hand right now it fits in
my hand because
the available space in a modern car is
about the size of a baseball
the sensors here as you can see as we're
talking they are picking up
our breath robert straussberger leads a
group of over a dozen top car makers
joining forces with mothers against
drunk driving
to back the driver alcohol detection
system for safety
or dads verify me
warning alcohol detected here's how it
works
the sensor can detect the blood alcohol
content on your breath all in the matter
of seconds
if it's above the legal limit 0.08 the
ignition
won't turn joe belvedere helping to test
the system just had two shots of alcohol
car not started the keys electronically
taken away
but when i took the driver's seat sober
please provide breath sample to sensor
no alcohol detected the screen turns
green and i'm on my way
since each of us processes alcohol
differently the makers are calibrating
this technology to account for differing
driver weights
weather conditions mask wearing and even
attempts to trick the system
example you're sitting much farther away
from the sensor
if you leaned over you would rule that
reading out
and for transportation businesses the
manufacturer says
this ensures the driver is 100 percent
safe
we really look at technology to help
safety and
and i think that's a huge benefit for
the traveling public
james river transportation in richmond
has been on the road
testing this technology for two years
this technology
actually provides us that extra benefit
of knowing our driver is going to be
safe with no
alcohol in their system a piece of mind
patricia kimmel sums up with a simple
question
why not require the technology to stop
anyone from driving
drunk
it's a very good point and the big news
today is that this technology is being
made available for
open source licensing this fall for
commercial companies so you could see it
installed in fleets and trucks
anytime soon they're constantly
improving the sensitivity
of its system and the hope is that this
could be an added safety feature
in your car in the near future so
parents for example
could add this to their vehicle to make
sure their teens don't drive with any
alcohol
in their system anthony yeah errol that
would certainly provide a lot of comfort
to a lot of people i mean i don't know
how much further they need to develop
this technology but
it's i mean it literally will save lives
yeah yeah and i know there's no test for
that other uh drug called marijuana
but other drugs would be also key
because you know in many states it's now
legal yeah
it's just sad that with so much
education that we've had about not
drinking and driving that you still
have thousands of people every year that
die from that and get behind the wheel
yeah